saturday would have been the 22nd
birthday of mofana sebeli mabusa's son
sandele died three days ago after being
caught in violent pro-democracy protests
when he went to the mobile phone store
mabusa says a witness told him his
firstborn was shot in the back by a
police officer and left to die and to
make these ways
they don't care
about our children and about our future
because my son jenna j
tomorrow he was going to be something
something big not even to me maybe even
to this country the government says
since pro-democracy protests began in
june 35 people have died amnesty
international says that number is much
higher more than 80. many people are now
saying something that was once
inconceivable in africa's last absolute
monarchy that after 35 years of rule
king maswati the third has enriched
himself while ignoring the struggles of
the people and it's time for his reign
to end and a new era of democracy to
begin wandeli lulu is the
secretary-general of one of the largest
political parties in eswatini a 1973
decree bans parties from sponsoring
candidates to run for parliament he says
all the corruption in the country can be
traced back to the king he does not give
a damn to human life that's how divorced
and corrupt
he has become we have been taking the
beating hoping that one day the ears of
the king will open and he will listen
but clearly
like all despots and detectors yes he's
not listening king maswati says he hopes
to launch a national dialogue in the
coming months and called for peace in
this country of just over one million
people
former babani deputy mayor jabulani
numalo says eswatini needs to address
corruption and that lies with parliament
we are at a very
precarious painful
a agonizing
phase
but what is good is that we all agree
that we don't deserve this
we can do better than this
now the beginning in my
humble submission is that let everybody
withdraw
the anger and let's come together
go forward
at the moment mabusa isn't sure how he
and his family will be able to do that
they have yet to bury san dile
people have described as swatini as one
big family but there is no sign yet that
family is ready to heal
natasha ghanim al jazeera and babani
eswatini